when the Apollo program was coming to an
end von Braun was running through the
halls of Congress trying to convince
congressmen that the next project after
the Apollo program should be sending
humans to Mars unlike many other
proposals he had made in the past that
proposal actually ended up on the desk
of President Richard M Nixon now a lot
of people don't understand this but the
president is not only the commander in
chief he's the commander in chief of
NASA NASA is actually an administrative
function in our government and it
reports directly to the President of the
United States so in the early 70s Nixon
had two proposals sitting on his desk
one was let's send somebody to Mars the
competing proposal was the space show
now the Space Shuttle originally was a
very cool concept it is exactly what
Elon Musk is trying to do with rockets
right now by making them reusable and it
was a relatively small space plane that
could shuttle astronauts into Earth
orbit and then where you would have the
capability of building a larger rocket
that could go on to places like Mars
unfortunately in the military and the
intelligence agencies in the United
States became very interested in the
space shuttle and and a conflict
developed Nixon chose the space shuttle
over going to Mars over von Vaughn's
program and shortly thereafter von Braun
resigned from NASA and not long after
that he died had Nixon chosen in the
early 70s to go to Mars instead of
building the Space Shuttle we would have
a colony on Mars now and there would
probably be thousands of people there
the tragedy of the Space Shuttle was
that it was really kind of designed for
the military-industrial complex rather
than what NASA really had in mind
originally which was a cheap small
reusable rocket the joke is that there
were 11 secret missions that we know of
between 1982 and 1992 and which used the
Space Shuttle for military and
intelligence purpose
we have no real idea what those were
they were classified but we do know that
they existed and that those rockets were
launched and used for that purpose here
is a government agency that from day one
was supposed to be completely open and
transparent because we did not want
other countries thinking that we looked
like explorers of space and we looked
like people who were only interested in
intellectual curiosity and finding out
more about our environment when in fact
at the same time we were doing military
things so for the last five decades from
1970 at least the space program has been
stunted and as absolute has gone
absolutely nowhere and that's why we
have people like SpaceX who are going to
be the first to go to land on Mars
because they've created this huge hole
of low-cost entry into space and
governments are now losing control of
space that they've had as a monopoly and
private companies are finding it quite
easy to do things faster better and
cheaper than NASA or the military can do
them and they're going to get into long
term space first
you